normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government it's
from sr.com black lives matter leader
who endorsed Trump tells Fox News the
Democratic party is not for us will we
get uh you know let me just we'll throw
it back we'll go back in time the meme
war was so much fun it was just all the
memes were hilarious excuse me excuse me
will be fun because El has just declared
a new one and that's my point this is
what I bring up yeah with a a black
lives matter leader saying you know what
the Democratic part is not for us Trump
is winning uh uh I should say he's
improving among younger voters among
black and Latino voters Joe Biden's just
in a horrible position and I have no
idea how they could reasonably swap out
Joe Biden at this point are we going to
have a Resurgence of
2016 is it going to be the great meme
War the the jokes the Trump the Trump
debate style I think that would be great
because that really got people excited
it got people excited and and thought
that everyone was on the same team you
know um and I wasn't part of it at all
but it did look fun at the time from the
outside it did look fun from the outside
and you could kind of get the sense that
something was coming and you weren't
expecting it I don't know magic I don't
know anything about the meme War I uh
never had conversations with Ricky vaugh
or Cod rad stump or uh any of those oh
you weren't involved at all Jack's a
general
not in any way involved in serious
pillow salesman I I'm just I am but a
humble pillow Merchant and an CL I just
want to make sure that I've been looking
at your screen throughout the evening
and just I don't know what creep did you
say
creep and it just doesn't seem to be the
mypillow.com website just you must not
be a very good sales I'm so
concerned so concerned all sales that
you might be missing when your your
order you have to get it delivered in
time for for for the I just don't know
why you're not doing this
Christmas only we had a good pillow
Merchant in the room to convince me to
buy something but isn't it actually
really wild how hard they went after a
guy who sells pillows it's like is this
your biggest threat dude but his
reaction to them calling his pillows
lumpy oh that was amazing I mean he like
how dare you don't call my
pillow his Integrity his product which I
honestly respect you know everyone in
the world respected that because even I
even saw people in like Silicon
retweeting that saying like never attack
a Founder's business never do this and
your lumpy pillow like you're lumpy
you're lumpy you're like and just and
just lights up just lights the guy up
just goes and especially because he's
known as like and I I talked to Mike
right like he's he's legitimately one of
the nicest guys um he's an extremely
devout Christian I mean he will straight
up like if you need some i' I've heard
him say he said this publicly so I'll
just say it um he'll straight up say
like if you get stuck somewhere if you
want to come event he will send a
private jet for you wow like wow
anywhere if you if you truly need it and
you're trying to get somewhere and
you're in a bind like I've heard him do
that for people so many times and even
people that aren't in politics it's just
someone he knows that has trouble he oh
send the jet don't worry about it
everything will be fine and and he'll
just do that and then just just I don't
know how he he just just takes it the
price we need to make sure the younger
generation that wasn't I mean look it's
it's going to be 2024 so it's nearly 10
years since uh 2016 race it'll be it'll
be eight and there's going to be a lot
of uh you know early 20s gen Z people
who are not old enough to have seen the
meme magic and beautiful times but but
really I'm not making a jokes real quick
people real quick people need don't
understand this meme magic was a
reference to the very strange
occurrences that happened online where
memes so on 4chan for instance when you
make a post you get an ID number and
weird things would happen with numbers
lining up in certain ways uh it it it
was it was the it's just wild the the
Serendipity and The Coincidence around
people posting memes and how weird
things are to coincide with the posts
well and and not just the post but the
way that it actually affected and
influenced reality and so had an
influence on the real world uh Hillary's
health I think probably was one of the
biggest ones of these so we started
hashtag Hillary's health and we kept
saying there's something wrong with her
there's something wrong and at the time
she was like was that was it before the
9111 incident thing or like get
um so do you want me do you want to hear
the story or not I mean I was
there brother um yeah maybe in the third
hour
booom or or maybe at amfest also promo
code post so which I hear Tim
will public I believe we're confirmed
for amfest yeah do you have any guests
for amfest Tim I don't know if we're
allowed to say it are we uh I got a text
that said to go ahead and say it so
Tucker Carlson so timcast Tucker Carlson
will be live on on stage amf.com get
your tickets now do not come crying to
me when the thing is sold out which
happens every single year one of these
things people go oh Poo can you get me
in get me a couple tickets couple of
comps man like I know you got the hook
up I you know Charlie like I ain't doing
it like I'm just straight up not doing
it so yeah Charli I think I know
Charlie's gonna be on this is the on
stage so you're bringing you're bringing
the show out right the show is going to
be on stage at amfest and our guests I
believe are Tucker Carlson and Charlie
Kirk yes it's going to be awesome so
that's that's that's you're doing
Patrick B David I know Tucker's going to
be broadcasting from there bannon's war
room I'm going to be doing my show
Charlie's doing his show Patrick B David
is going to be also live streaming from
there he's not just appearing he's also
going to be doing live so like you're
going to get the value tainment like
dude those guys are awesome I love it's
just everybody I think it's literally
just everyone's back post millennial the
post millennial would be there we're
going to have a booth post millennial's
got a booth we're going to have people
if I mean like imagine not going to
infest it was it it's not easy to do
like um to to get a
doing a show on stage like this requires
a lot I remember last year it was wild
it was definitely wild and so we have to
as soon as the show WS were on a on a on
a on a Jet right back because we had to
do the show Tuesday I got to do the
morning show too but when uh we were we
were talking and we said we want to do a
big show they well if you get in trouble
I know a guy he's got a jet you to buy a
lot of pillows I heard the whole
jet they taking care of us they're
they're they're helping take care of
everything it's fantastic and so I'm
really excited for this they were like
you know let's get let's get Tu on stage
it be cool it's going to be I feel like
Tucker coming on the show is a long time
coming I feel like a lot of people have
wanted to see see the mash up they us at
the exact same time right so you
couldn't I mean there was no way to make
that work yeah we were as couldn't go on
Tucker Tucker couldn't go on Tim but
after he left Fox we actually I I don't
know I think our people reached out and
it was a like oh yeah for sure we'll
figure it out and then we just never did
it's the same thing that happens with
Trump we get like we we had Laura Trump
on the show and she's like yeah of
course let's make it happen I'm like
cool and then we just never do it and so
I'm like I don't know I kind of feel
like if SL when we have Trump on it
should it should be it should shouldn't
just be us pursuing it for the sake of
pursuing it it should be like at a time
where it really oh matters um speaking
of which so I did actually discuss this
with speaking of amfest I did discuss
this with Charlie earlier and you know
so you know we were kind of going
through because I knew there were some
names that haven't come out yet um so on
on Trump no news yet no no news yes or
no leaning towards I mean come on he
really ought to come you know um I I I
would I would say it's probably likely
he gets hero welome but no news um uh VI
is confirmed uh Chris Christ Chris
Christie just total no response he just
didn't say anything no response and and
again like Turning Point reached out to
every single Turning Point action but
you know Chris chrisy just the other day
on the news was saying how his campaign
was really picking up steam uh no was
picking up cream actually that it was
that was the he was he was at chis cream
yeah cream so so no you just you must
have heard of or maybe he misspoke um so
Nikki Haley um you know Pro probably not
um Ronda santis Governor Ronda santis um
again because the offer went out
everywhere so this de santis is coming
now it's the opposite so um there was a
conversation that was being held uh the
conversation is now over um from what
Charlie told me you know just prior to
the show to now uh Ronda santis will not
be attending amfest he found out I was
coming after after I descri SN after I
just described every single entity
organization group all the hottest
podcasts in the entire country are going
to be there and but they're all their
heights are publicly known many of which
many of one of which he was just on uh
many of which are from Florida uh yeah
he has decided to decline to come to
Turning Point again I think that's crazy
too it okay which is the largest
conservative Grassroots event in the
entire country he basically says he's
running for president yeah and he
doesn't like he's going to debate a
governor what tomorrow right yeah and he
doesn't care about strange reason he
just keeps it's like he keeps saying
that he just doesn't care about the base
conservatives in this country he doesn't
want their vote he goes on all of the
other networks he snubs Turning Point
like it's really crazy how he does that
and thinks that people what do he
actually think people are going to come
around and be like oh you won't show up
you won't talk to anybody and they keep
saying that and it it's very strange to
me it's perplexing because I've been at
Turning Point events in the past where
Ronda Santa spoke and as prior to him
announcing that he was running against
Trump but um where he was given a
standing ovation by the crowd they they
loved him um and I I don't think it
would be an unfriendly you know hostile
event in any way that being said you
know it's a primary bro you know you got
to go into these things but the
perception of it is just so bad
you look weak you look terrified if he
showed up the response from the Trump
supporters would be to shake his hand
and say I respect everything you're
doing in Florida I hope you understand
why we're supporting Trump but I think
you're doing a good job they wouldn't
attack him and that's his opportunity to
to make a case you know what I think I
don't think he has an argument thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 800m and become a
member over at
timcast.net membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time